hello and welcome to this video playing
sky 777 and get a bishops opening
bishops game the ship's game I don't
know exactly what the term is there okay
so let me need to think about this a
little bit yeah the check is right I
didn't have this on the board all that
much it's not so commonly seen the check
is some is an important idea
it gives black why provokes white to
play see three images not the most
testing way of playing this this opening
line oftentimes wide wants to place the
knight on c3 and that is not possible
anymore
so here this position is obviously quite
symmetrical and should be fine for me I
think Nancy for I can go to c7 that's
that's a fine position what do I want to
do here I can try to get the knight - to
g6 possibly also to e6
yeah Knights e5 e6 okay now this is
maybe the moment you get this reboot
this regrouping on the road
why does not castling get that is a
little bit a little bit surprising yeah
then he hadn't he had a plan connected
to this omission of castling I don't
think it's a good plan
really because I get them I get them
let's say I get the first strike and
this is a little bit awkward now I mean
he cannot really take it I think maybe
maybe sorry maybe he can take it and
then put the knight on to c2 or
something again okay now um f5 him know
what do I just cancel I mean I have to
cancel at some point let's cancel first
I always get nervous yeah the quinoa you
ate even though there is no threat yeah
there's no threat okay here I have to
take and now if all looks kind of normal
but maybe maybe not
maybe not he might have the capture and
rookie one I can take g2 that is an
interesting alternative I see nothing
wrong with that actually let's take it
it prevents rupee one and okay you can
go rook g1 I go to f4 and what's on
what's what's up nothing
nothing really and the moment I had
placed c5 or a5 I'm having my own ideas
link this one
this is actually it looks like a very
safe King positioner the knight on f6 s
cannot be attacked and it looks quite
safe this is one reason why I took the
Jeep on I mean as long if there is a
Jeep on the board there's always g4 g5
in in some way and this is something
that now I don't have to worry about
maybe he just plays rook e1 here
no just takes a tank simply attacking c6
and C getting the Queen close no it's
really no way to do that so let's cover
the pawn and I'm still have a 5 a 4 so
godly father
hmm 22 I always looked at move I did not
see that coming no that's that's that's
a bit that's a bit of an issue
that's a problem it really is a problem
that is less than ideal
[Music]
always funny if they play play moves
like cringes sex him crazy and I don't
even think it was that great I Scott
night geez 96 but 96 yeah very nice that
is secure I mean honestly what white did
here was really terrible really terrible
and I should never lose but I did I need
this is just not working at all there's
this whole thing with giving up the Jeep
on and so on
okay so Knight f4 Quincy - yeah and I
just yeah this is just good for luck I
mean equal going to the engine okay yeah
sorry that can never be good for white
or anything I should never lose in six
moves and it's just bad so yeah I did
not see a three this is yeah not exactly
difficult but I didn't see it and I have
to play Bishop e5
yeah Bishop e5 in order to move the
knight and then I have okay this is the
move that would give me an advantage so
something like this where the bishop is
covering because I mean this is the
thing he cannot attack me here with
normal means like just mechanically it
doesn't work because g7 I can always
cover it has to be some kind of some
kind of outlandish thing like Queen g6m
otherwise nothing would work just so
save and this wins of course Queen g6m I
haven't only I have no good move Jim
I'm Bishop e5 Kevin and this is then
okay can already take f7 oh that's a
cute one yeah that's a good tactic and
know which is emblem yeah g7 I cannot
take you to 96 and yeah what do you do
here
yeah I can go here yeah what wins now
probably more than one more Queen yeah I
was simply taking woodwind and it was
even stronger
but yeah Queen g6 is strong if he
doesn't have that one that's that's a
move I didn't see when I was playing I
mean I also overlooked Bishop of seven
of course but I anticipated Queen g2
Queen have aid and I didn't see Queen g6
yeah it's a move that he just made like
instantly okay Jim no now I have to give
up age six I obviously didn't spot 96
the only thing I can do now is to
basically take on d4 and continue this
but it's it's lost of course it's lost
now hmm that's an odd game I really
don't believe in this at all I mean like
not at all maybe I didn't even play it
right there b5 oh I can simply take a
four Wow oh it was a terrible game then
I can't just you just blundered this
pawn
okay and the engine finds Bishop d5 I
don't think that he planned to smooth
just blundered blundered upon that is a
very cool idea Knight takes c3 computer
chess yeah that looks good for black but
who plays like that I should have at
least seen that I mean I only spotted
that I'm okay here but in fact the
engine says that this is good for white
it's something
and then I only saw after playing it and
indeed the movie 5 is a huge problem
here that makes neither for a double
mistake it's it's it's just bad in
itself and I can take on your form
probably even be five isn't the best
move maybe if I can take it form it is
maybe the best move plan anyway
I overlooked two too many things in this
game thanks a lot for watching